I love this movie so much you guys seem
like you got close making it yeah you've
never worked together before right and
then you had to punch each other right
and there's a bond that forms when you
do that
the reasons actually there is like you
know fake fight somebody something
happens just shut your mouth and let me
do my thing all right what was it like
to pretend punch Matt Damon was it more
intimidating to punch Batman no that
fight was actually it was the it's the
silliest fight so it was actually it was
fun to do a fight for once where we
could learn the choreography in like 15
minutes and versus you know you know
some of these fight scenes we do you
gotta really you're suppose we're
supposed to look like we know what we're
doing and that means kind of learning it
like a like a dance and so it takes a
long time and you got to do it with the
person you're doing it with and it's all
it's a whole kind of thing so this is
really fun this is two completely
useless middle-aged guys in a fight
where they don't actually want to hurt
each other you just went for it I was
actually really trying to hurt you just
that in effect is this that's like boxer
you went down too many weight classes
then quickly I loved Matt you just told
this story about a real fight that you
and Ben Affleck were in together as kids
was that moment a moment where you knew
I got a friend for life in this guy yeah
yeah definitely I mean one of many
moments he looks so good lately are you
loving just seeing him happy yeah I know
he's looking great and he's doing great
and I've been we've been working
together on this screenplay and know
he's doing he's just doing great in the
movie Carol Shelby he gives this great
speech and he talks about how some
people are driven they just have to do
something
do you guys both feel that way about
acting I do I like to say about
storytelling
yeah really yes yeah and that is that is
nice to have an obsession nitin honestly
it's kind of like a love-hate thing but
that's what obsession is is it's not
because it's
godless of loving it hating it if you
feel a lot about it you're gonna feel
both at some point but yes it is nice to
I also loved watching Noah's character
the way he had this look in his eyes
seeing his dad race and and being at the
track with him I wondered if you guys
bring your own kids on set do they look
at you that same way my kids they only
want to go to craft service got it
we need a snack the actual quote is that
your work is really boring but the craft
service is good okay guys so that's how
they're judging your movies how good
were the snacks right yeah
do any of them want to get into acting
just like he wanted to get into racing
mm-hmm I think just in a sort of a fun
way of seeing what it's like you know
and they'll come to the set and dress up
and you know occasionally walk in the
background or whatever you know you can
do that and they joy that but then they
also realize how many takes it takes
usually they like you kidding me they've
seen the reality door has been you know
there is an extra before and I'm walking
past she's going dad get it right you
know how many more times you got do this
can i play the quickest game with you
guys okay your character comes up with a
shelby this is a car right okay
so we're playing the car name game we
have real car names and fake ones just
guess which ones real and which ones a
fake model the Isuzu mystery utility
wizard no that can't be real the
ministry which is no mystery utility the
mysterious utility Wister you tell that
he was very game it's a mysterious
utility wizard it's really new it's
Suzie dental muw yeah the Ferrari
California extra caliph Ferrari
California there is a California there
is a Ferrari California why would there
be an extra because it's what's there's
an extra fee on it sell it to the guy
who needs just something more than the
California you think the guy who's
neighbor about the California Laura
Kelly wants to buy the F Sierra real or
fake it's real I'm sorry Jay okay last
one the Ford Focus flex well there is a
Ford
legs ford focus flex fusion yes real
yeah that's got to be real that's fake
do we do we get any no we with the
movies great thank you
[Music]